my gosh again california girl and megan
seems to have wasted no time showing
prince harry her california ways
last night i have the best food
i had a great burger i love fries
especially if they're from in and out et
has learned that the duke and duchess of
sussex have been stopping by the west
coast fast food chain
on their 90-minute road trips from la to
santa barbara
i definitely try to eat as clean as
possible but i am also a foodie
so on the weekends all bets are off
according to a source the couple has hit
up the in and out drive through
several times on their way back from
meetings with their most recent visit
being
last monday following a preschool garden
planting event
the source says that all the employees
nearly lost their minds
adding quote they were all yelling and
laughing and could not believe
megan and harry were ordering burgers
from the drive-thru
plus rumor has it harry has already
learned about the burger joints
secret menu it's magic it's pretty
amazing
harry and megan relocated from la to
santa barbara
earlier this summer e.t previously
learned that the couple purchased a
nine-bedroom
19-bathroom home with a price tag of
14.6 million dollars
i never thought my life would be that
awesome meanwhile the couple has also
settled their debt on their uk-based
frogmore cottage
a spokesperson for the sussexes tells et
that
harry has repaid the 3.1 million dollars
that they spent on renovating the
windsor england home
which will remain their primary uk
residence
it's good to be home what's more another
source tells et
that megan and terry are now financially
independent
adding that the sussexes are quote no
longer receiving financial support
from harry's dad prince charles we are
taking a leap of faith
so thank you for giving me the courage
to take this next step
the news comes several days after e.t
confirmed
that megan and harry signed a major
production deal
with netflix they've also been busy
giving back to their new community
last week megan and harry volunteered
with local la non-profit
baby to baby passing out necessary
supplies to families
and helping kids pick out and try on new
backpacks
we're a fantastic team we know we are
you